All right. So I'm having a tough time figuring out if I'm picking the right keywords. So I just
went back to the keywords that you created. Okay. So I'm doing like a ton of analysis. Maybe I'm
doing too much. I'm analyzing like 26 keywords because I wrote it. I'm a programmer. So I wrote
an app to do all this for me. I'm not doing it manually. So I'm running like 26 keywords per city
and that's the screenshots I put in. So am I doing too much? Like how do I know
if those cities I pasted in are actually good? Yeah, I think you're doing too much. I mean,
look, I think people like you, I swear to you, and I mean this as a compliment, you guys are too
smart. The reason why this model works really well for people like me is because I'm like, all right,
I don't even have the patience to do more than like five or seven. I don't think you need more
than five or seven keywords to analyze a city. Okay. All right. So the second part was...
Let me say one last thing. So like tree service, I know that the lists are in here. I can share
those too. And guys, if you guys have lists or you've seen lists I've shared in the past,
that would be awesome for you guys to reshare those. I can also go and find them. But tree
service, you're looking at... Well, let's use concrete because it's just the one that was used.
So concrete is the core keyword. Then you got concrete contractors. I think concrete company,
concrete patio, concrete driveway, concrete sidewalk. There might be one more. I'm going
to use those keywords plus the city. And that's going to be enough for me to say yes or no on a
city.